the most explosive book yet from an
insider in the Trump Whitehouse flip
sims is talking and it sounds like he
has a bit of a beef with the
communications office in the White House
a new book by a former Trump
administration staff member shedding
some light on a White House he describes
his absolutely out of control chaos in
the Oval Office that's been the story
for two years according to report after
report boy a lot of excitement about a
new tell-all book from former White
House staffer Cliff Simms it's getting
so much media attention as you can see
here Simms who served in the White House
for 500 days the president and I are
sitting just off the Oval Office in the
private study and we're creating what
China by mounts to an enemies list of
people in the White House who I felt
were basically disloyal to him as his
pension for putting two rival staff
members in a room and letting them fight
it out over an issue does breed some of
this competitive aspect it's already a
tough place to work did you ever leak no
no talk about everything in here that I
feel like I should have done differently
and President Trump is slamming simms
calling him a quote low-level staffer
who was nothing more than a gofer and
who was quote a mess the Trump campaign
also saying it will sue Simms for
violating violating a confidentiality
agreement so Jedediah let's just go over
some the biggest I think reveal here was
one in which he's goes into Kellyanne
Conway's office and you and he can see
all the reporters calling Kelly and even
as she's saying it's somebody else who's
leaking and they're not being loyal and
Kelly Hanks come back and said this is
nonsense the leakers are the ones who
are getting a good press
I mean he's not embarrassed this guy to
go I mean I don't understand these
people that sign these NDA's and go in
and have these high-level meetings with
the president and then clearly want to
be on TV want to sell a books or just
willing to tell the whole story I think
he should get sued I don't know if
anything will come of that
but the precedent it sets I mean this
guy came off like a weasel to me and
he's sitting in and talking to Allison
Cammarata on new day and she interrupts
the interview and she says oh by the way
do you know that Trump just tweeted and
he goes really he looked like a kid who
had just gotten a lot of good idea
because
- Ian Moir book yeah he was like oh wow
I got attention and I would just caution
Trump against that just because you're
giving this guy even more attention and
the fact that you might dislike him now
or you've got beef with him that's only
gonna make the media love them more I
just can't believe we live in a country
where you can take a high-profile
position where you're trusted to value
confidentiality and with potentially
high national security information at
times or high security information and
you go in and you abuse that that right
that privilege to have a job like that
and you just decide well I want to write
a tell-all like you're like you work for
The Enquirer I mean this guy's a joke I
think he was chosen by Trump but still
that's something you've chosen for a
position like that I mean this is a
privilege to get I think this is
something other people table even have
said in the past you know boy it's a lot
of strange guys that have come around
Trump but anyway yes let me ask you
something
I noticed that this book even if it's
somewhat salacious and ridiculous
it fits with what you heard from
Woodward from Michael Wolfe from Omarosa
about chaos in the White House how do
you interpret well I'm about a third of
the way through the book and I really
like it see Dana I do read taste in
books Jesse thank you very much Dana
it's a positive portrayal of the
president they say how engaging he is
how intelligent he is how connected he
is to the people it was a very
flattering portrayal of the president
very flattering portrayal of about 75%
of the rest of the people he had
negative things to say about Paul Ryan
at one point he told a great story about
how Trump in the middle of an oval
office meeting where Paul Ryan's boring
the heck out of him for 30 minutes on
health care policy Trump just leaves
walks out starts watching TV in the den
and he's just sitting there like what
what just happened also very negative
portrayal of Sean Spicer not a good
manager and they take us through how
they did the whole crowd size first
press conference and how that was a
debacle and how he stole a little
mini-fridge from one of his staffers but
all in all this guy's from Alabama
devout Christian his father was a pastor
mother was a Sunday school teacher who
was a Cruz supporter
vo guy and was really disgusted after
the Access Hollywood tape almost left
the campaign because it couldn't handle
it he said to himself
you know what as long as Hillary's not
gonna be in the White House I'm gonna
stick it out with Trump I'm gonna stick
it out and then leak well I'm very
particular particularly strong feelings
about this a friend of mine who knows
him suggested that he wants to be
Alabama's on morosa it's not a
compliment okay that's a and is is what
I think I don't care what may have
happened in kellyanne's office if you
are the staffer and you're there like do
you think that it's inappropriate you
should resign but I think it's very
highly inappropriate to then go sell a
book and especially while the president
is still in office and yes maybe the
book is portrays the president
positively but it doesn't matter if
they're in a new cycle that is not good
for them right now this guy goes out and
makes a million dollars advance for a
book a million dollars made a million
for this book and he goes out and it
will be very hard for him to be trusted
again by anyone and he's a talented
young person and I think that he has a
lot he had a lot of promise I think it
was a bad decision he could have written
this book after the administration and
that would have been a better time to do
it Gregg Jon Cal he says that John Kelly
the former chief of staff said oh if
Trump wants to fire me be the best day
of my life another sort of you know
admission by people oh yeah everybody
was going to be the adult in the room to
try to counter Trump even in his own
description of why he stayed the there
is no tell-all in the history of tell
all that is flattering to the subject or
the tell-all wouldn't exist because when
you sit down with a publisher what they
want is controversy they want scandal
and they push you and they progr
to get the stuff out when you submit a
your first draft and it doesn't have
enough crap in it in fact they look at
you like you betrayed them you've got to
have Terry we need to have between that
and then you have the media gobble it up
as if they're like crack addicts in the
sense that they forget it's an ephemeral
high and it often doesn't last and it's
yeah and so and I also don't like the
fact that this guy is using his devout
Christianity as a shield like
that'sthat's it no it's money dude it's
not it's not God it's green that is
forcing you to do this now we've got
we're gonna have to presidential
libraries we're gonna have a one that's
its traditional one and one for
tell-alls you've never been better than
anybody then for the publishing industry
but my last point and I'll shut up if
you're CEO if you're a boss if you're an
interesting person if you've done a lot
in your life the tell-all will come and
it will be bad because the people who
write to tell all they don't understand
you they don't know why you get mad they
don't know why you are impulsive they
don't understand your reasoning so when
you're happy one minute and mad the
other or you leave the room or you yell
at somebody they're going like what what
he's obviously an awful person no you're
just an idiot you don't understand
when is the gutfeld tell-all coming I
have no idea on planning now but Greg
you didn't but you weren't bothered that
you have people like Omarosa and cliff
Sims on the inside the same story I
think he made poor choices of people but
that's cuz he didn't he wasn't didn't
know he was gonna win all right